Kristopher have you plays tormund
Giantsbane and Game of Thrones
the big bearded wildling leader with a
soft spot for Brienne of Tarth his views
character has quickly become a fan
favorite but what else is a norwegian
actor appeared in why does he look so
familiar the thing although he had
appeared on a few Norwegian TV shows and
one feature film his views break into
international cinema came when he was
cast as one of the Arctic researchers in
2011's the thing a prequel to the 1982
John Carpenter classic his views turn in
the widely panned horror flick didn't
win in many Awards but it puts him on
American casting directors radar setting
the wheels in motion for his eventual
role in Game of Thrones in 2013 after
earth the thing may not have lived up to
expectations but he views next two movie
2013's after earth gave him a real crash
course and how badly things can go for a
major motion picture problem started for
the actor when he showed up on set and
the makeup artist decided to cut off his
long hair and bushy beard a decision he
fought even getting star Jaden Smith to
back him up but the makeup crew won in
the end after earth was more critically
so maybe losing the beard was worth it
it makes him harder to recognize in a
movie he'd probably rather forget force
majeure if you return to his
Scandinavian roots of 2014's force
majeure a dark comedy that follows a
downtrodden husband in an unhappy
marriage he view who plays the best
friend character told scam magazine it
was a refreshing change of pace I didn't
have a sword in my hand I wasn't
climbing a nice wall but playing a
normal man as an actor you always want
to be extraordinary but to play an
ordinary man is a really big challenge
that challenge had a huge payoff if you
took the Award for Best Supporting Actor
at the Scandinavian equivalent to the
Oscars in 2015 in order of disappearance
that same year
if you played a gangster who gets beaten
up by Swedish acting legend stellan
skarsgård in the darkly funny revenge
drama in order of disappearance the
movie follows a father who goes after a
local drug gang in revenge for killing
his son the film acclaimed for its
artful blend of black comedy and bloody
violence has been described as a
Scandinavian version of Fargo
Lillehammer if you rounded out a busy
2014 with a part in
Netflix's norwegian-american crime-drama
Lillehammer which follows a former
american mafia bus hiding out in norway
if you appeared in the episode foreign
affairs in a small role as a greenpeace
worker sharp-eyed viewers may have
noticed an allusion to his views Game of
Thrones kick during one scene a
television clearly shows his view as
tormund in a scene from the HBO hit the
last king in 2016 if you got to act out
one of the most important events in
Norwegian history the protection of a
future king during the Norwegian civil
wars by a group of patriotic warriors if
you grew up learning the 11th century
story that inspired the last King in
school and he was excited about the role
the characters in the movie spend a lot
of time on skis believe it or not since
I was the fastest way for medieval
Norwegians to get around which led to
some risky stunts for heavier back the
Scandinavian police procedure will back
has gone through many changes during its
20-year run including casting her view
as the new partner of the show's
namesake police detective Martin Beck
Viera police enlist cliana whose names
on the story of the burst him as a
longtime fan of the show if you eagerly
accepted the chance to join the cast
telling scam magazine before he got the
gig I have played many bad guys and
villainous roles so to play a cop will
be great fun and very cool the fate of
the Furious effuse most high-profile
movie role came courtesy of 2017 the
fate of the Furious in which he played
Connor Rhodes right-hand man and muscle
for main villain cypher played by
Charlize Theron if you was a huge fan of
The Fast and Furious franchise before he
got his chance to join it and he also
wasn't the only game of Thrones star in
the movie
Natalie Emmanuel who plays Masson Day
returned as Ramsay the cruise hacker
Wyndham rewards commercials now while he
view usually plays dark violent roles he
can be silly when necessary
like when he started playing the
eccentric wild-eyed Windham rewards
wizard in the hotel chains a string of
commercials clearly the greatest part of
his career not convinced observe are we
in the future actually were in Branson
Missouri
but Papa and now you got all the
breakfast you can eat yeah thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love tea
[Applause]
you